story Fox News and Dominion voting
systems agree a settlement worth nearly
800 million dollars over claims about
the rigging of the 2020 U.S election fox
has admitted to telling lies about
Dominion that caused enormous damage to
my company our employees and the
customers that we serve
also tonight the SLP in crisis after the
treasurer is arrested and then released
over the party's funding and finances
what is certain to derail what you're
talking about here in Parliament this
afternoon it certainly is not helpful of
course
yeah
a U.S journalist jailed in Moscow is
seen for the first time in court his
appeal against attention is rejected the
charges against Evan are baseless and we
call on the Russian Federation to
immediately release him
the U.S UK and Canadian ambassadors are
summoned to the Russian foreign Ministry
accused of gross interference
just stop snooker tens of thousands of
climate activists to demonstrate this
weekend as groups say they will continue
with disruption
tough rules to stop energy suppliers
forcing homeowners over 85 to switch to
prepayment meters but critics say the
ban doesn't go far enough
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening the voting
machine company Dominion has settled
with Fox News tonight for more than
787 million dollars it was announced
less than an hour ago just before both
sides were due to deliver their opening
statements in court Dominion which sells
electronic voting hardware and software
had been suing Fox News Network over its
coverage of false vote rigging claims in
the 2020 U.S election a U.S corresponder
Mark Stone joins us live now from
outside the courthouse in Delaware and
Mark Dominion exacting a heavy price for
this out of court deal
yes Fox will be paying
787 and a half million dollars to
Dominion this has been an extraordinary
day of drama of suspense and at the
heart of it uh it is a story of Truth a
story of Lies a story of an election and
a story of the most influential of All
American cable news channels Fox news
that it went right to the wire as you
say uh a little over half an hour or so
ago Dominion were out on the steps here
at the courthouse in Wilmington Delaware
where they're they're voting machines
company is headquartered to announce
that indeed a settlement had come but it
really was went right to the wire the
the trial was supposed to begin
yesterday late on Sunday night
dramatically the judge announced it
would be delayed by a day was that to
discuss a potential settlement well it
turns out it was today a the jury was
sworn in they were expecting six men six
women from here in Delaware expecting to
sit through five weeks of extraordinary
legal drama and at the end of it they
would come to the conclusion whether or
not Fox had lied whether it had
knowingly broadcast stuff that was
nonsense that was not true the hours
went by two and a half almost three
hours and then the judge came into court
and he said the two sides have settled I
then watched as Fox news's lawyers
Rupert Murdoch's chief lawyer left
through a side door walked off um up the
street here in Wilmington he and his
colleagues said nothing but at that
moment a statement dropped into our
inboxes and I'll read a bit of it to you
it says and this is a fox statement we
are pleased to have reached a settlement
despite uh of our dispute with Dominion
voting systems we acknowledge the
Court's rulings finding certain claims
about Dominion to be false this
settlement reflects Fox his continued
commitment to the highest journalistic
standards we are hopeful that our
decision to resolve this dispute with
Dominion amicably instead of
acrimoniously
instead of the acrimony of a divisive
trial allows the country to move forward
from these issues um so the figure as I
said 787 and a half million dollars that
much will now be landing in the bank
accounts of dominion voting systems and
admission of guilt by Fox News they say
quite clearly certain claims about
Dominion were false what we don't yet
know Anna is the detail I imagine that
will come out there will be I'm sure
lengthy statements um that were shared
between these two companies that much
will be fascinating to find how much Fox
is claiming
um culpability for how much Dominion was
it was prepared to accept uh to to allow
this settlement to take place as I said
on the steps outside the court here a
few moments ago we heard from the boss
of dominion have a listen
Fox and Dominion have reached an
historic settlement
fox has admitted to telling lies about
Dominion
that caused enormous damage to my
company our employees and the customers
that we serve
nothing can ever make up for that
throughout this process we have sought
accountability
and believe the evidence brought to
light through this case underscores the
consequences of spreading lies
truthful reporting in the media is
essential to our democracy
a remarkable case then Anna That Never
Was a trial That Never Was of course
much of what Fox was up to has already
been released because in the pre-trial
Discovery period as it's known we
learned so much about the inner workings
of the fox Newsroom the Bonnet was
lifted on what they were really up to
fascinating stuff and I imagine the dust
will take quite some time to settle
Mark Stone updating us there from
Wilmington in Delaware thank you
well this case of course came after
Donald Trump's claims about vote rigging
in 2020 and the former president has
said he will run in the election next
year today former presidential candidate
and U.S Secretary State Hillary Clinton
told Sky News she does not believe her
former opponent Donald Trump can regain
the presidency following his recent
indictment she was speaking to our
political editor Beth Rigby in Belfast
where she's honoring women who
contributed to the peace process in
Northern Ireland as part of the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
even if he gets the Republican
nomination he cannot in my view be
re-elected uh president
why can't he be re-elected
I think people are more people are on to
him and his uh Behavior than they were
before he has a hardcore of support that
is likely to help him win the Republican
nomination but in a general election
against President Biden I do not believe
he can win
foreign to Scotland now where a second
person was arrested today over the
Scottish national party's funding and
finances column BT was detained by
police for questioning this morning and
this evening was released without charge
pending further investigations former s
p chief executive and Nicholas turgent
husband Peter Murrell was arrested two
weeks ago it's over more than 600 000
pounds raised for an independence
referendum campaign for today's arrest
was bad timing for the new first
Minister Hamza Yusuf who was giving a
speech in Parliament today sky Scotland
correspondent corrigalis has this report
[Music]
what you're talking about here in
Parliament this afternoon it certainly
is not helpful
the face of a first Minister fighting
the Flames of yet another fire yeah
yeah I don't really challenge him of
course any new leader any new first
Minister doesn't want to have to be
dealing with these challenges but
first one is the priorities of the
Scottish people today Hamza Yusuf was
hoping to reset his first major
parliamentary speech overshadowed amid
the arrest of the smp's treasurer this
was calling BT arriving home after being
detained by detectives for 12 hours they
are investigating the party's funding
and finances he was released without
charge there were no signs of police
activity at BT's home while he was in
custody a veteran of the Scottish
independence movement someone who was
treasured her for 16 years
after so long at the helm there was an
internal SMP election in 2020. Colin
Beatty was not related to The Post of
Treasurer however his successor did not
last long he resigned suggesting he did
not have enough information to do the
job properly at that point Colin Beatty
returned to the job the party's never
been in a stronger Financial position
than it is right
now a leaked video of Nicholas sturgeon
from 2021 in a meeting of the snp's
ruling body around the time police began
investigating 600 000 pounds raised for
a second independence vote
you know just be very careful
that there are problems with apache's
finances because we depend on donors to
donate there are no reasons for people
to be concerned about the party's
finances and all of us need to be
careful but not suggesting that there is
this is a difficult period for the party
so dominant there was a raid at the home
of the former first Minister and her
husband Peter Murrell on the day he was
arrested then released as part of the
probe after three weeks we already have
a lame duck first Minister and a lame
government and that's not good for our
country a woman two of difficulty for
those who recently stood for the SMP top
job I'm here in Parliament to talk about
how the first minister is going to
tackle poverty cost-living crisis invest
in our public sector and obviously the
parties engulfed in a crisis at the
moment what do you make of the party
itself certainly my focus will be on
delivering for my constituents do you
think that the SNP is at risk of
collapse no I don't
um I think obviously there is there are
clearly concerns right now you know it
would be
stand here and say that everything's
fine you know clearly that's not the
case
unease and uncertainty in a political
party enduring what has been described
as its biggest crisis in 30 years Conor
Gillis Sky News Edinburgh
and Connor joins us live now from
Glasgow so another arrest Conor and
another difficult day for the new SNP
leader
yeah Hamza Yusuf singing today he does
not believe the SNP is operating in a
criminal way but yes uh second arrest in
as many weeks Colin Beatty is not a big
public figure he's not in the high ranks
of public office here in Scotland but he
is very senior within the SNP as I was
saying in my report he also holds
positions on Hollywood committees there
are calls tonight from opposition
politicians for him to be suspended from
those committees while this
investigation continues at PACE at
Nicholas sturgeon the former first
Minister was not in Hollywood today she
was wanting to give way to Hamza Yusuf
for his big moment to reset and talk
about his priorities going forward well
clearly that did not happen due to this
police investigation I'm told a source
close to her this evening has said that
she will cooperate with any
investigation going forward but she has
no not been questioned as yet what
happens next with the police
investigation well clearly those
detectives will be going over those
interviews of Peter Murrow a number of
weeks ago and then clearly the SNP
Treasurer Colin Beatty who was released
without charge today before deciding and
plotting their next move
that's okay thank you
The Wall Street Journal correspondent
Evan gershkovic will stay in prisoner
Moscow and a weight trial after losing
his appeal to be released it was the
first time we've seen the journalists
since he was arrested soon after he
appeared in court the Russian foreign
Ministry summoned the UK U.S and
Canadian ambassadors who've been accused
of interfering in Russian Affairs Sky's
International correspondent John Sparks
has the story
Evan gershkovic has spent six years in
Russia reporting on the news
now he is the news after the authorities
arrested him for spying
this the first time he's been seen
publicly since the end of March like an
exhibit in a glass cabinet within a
Moscow courtroom
his lawyers applied for bail while the
authorities assembled their case
but gershkovich knew his chances were
Slim
kovich's arrest was trumpeted on state
television the host of this talk show
said he was trying to obtain classified
information about an arms Factory the
Enterprise a total failure she says
but the Americans call his detention
totally illegal The Ambassador in the
blue jacket casting a disapproving eye
after his plea for bail was denied she
made her displeasure known
[Applause]
the charges against Evan are baseless
and we call on the Russian Federation to
immediately release him
such comments have infuriated the
Russians here the British Ambassador
exits the foreign Ministry after a
diplomatic dressing down she and her
American counterpart accused of
interfering in the legal process
criticism of President Putin's
Administration and invasion is unwelcome
here solitary protests against the war
in Ukraine are quashed by police and
reporters must be careful what they say
but some analysts think there's another
reason the American was arrested it's
the kremlin's intention to create a pool
of hostages in order to
in order to bargain with the United
States about some Russians who was
detained in different Western countries
disputes in prisoner swaps form part of
the conflict but the fighting continues
in occupied Ukraine and the Russian
leader made a rare visit speaking to
commanders in the region of her son and
luhansk
I'm here to listen to your opinion he
said somewhat unconvincingly his
spokesman told Sky News you now see the
leader visiting the regions more often
that may be essential as some Russians
question his leadership their
commander-in-chief unable to win the war
John Sparks Sky News
Extinction rebellion and other climate
action groups have vowed to continue
protests unless the government meets
their demands up to 28 000 people are
expected to attend a mass demonstration
this weekend at the same time as the
London Marathon but event organizers say
they've had reassurances the marathon
will not be disrupted a climate change
and energy correspondent Hannah Thomas
Peter reports
an activist from the just stop oil
climate protest group disrupting the
world snooker championships in Sheffield
part of a dramatic evening in which
another activist succeeded in stopping
the game altogether
now just stop oil says there's more to
come the disruption will continue
there's millions of eyeballs on the
snooker so we've initiated millions of
conversations they're not actually
discussing the climate crisis now
they're discussing how annoying the
protest was that really disruptive
action is the only mechanism that normal
people have available to us in order to
force the necessary social change now
the junior doctors know that the nurses
know that the train drivers know that
open a history book every major Social
Development has been won by a small
minority who are highly unpopular at the
time unpopular sequitics but also
potentially counterproductive I think a
lot of people will see disrupting
sporting or other events that have
absolutely nothing to do with climate
changes nothing more than attention
seeking
perhaps that's why protests group the
extinction Rebellion is trying a
slightly different tactic this weekend
joining other groups in Coalition and
descending on Westminster for four days
of peaceful protest they are calling the
big one they've recently pulled back
from their old ways of doing things but
warn that won't last forever the
government has until 5 M on Monday the
24th of April to agree to enter
negotiation if we don't get a response
at 10 A.M on Tuesday 25th of April
Extinction Rebellion will build an
unprecedented Coalition stepping up our
campaigns in the weeks and months ahead
this now seems likely as their demands
especially stopping new oil and gas are
optimistic despite the expected presence
of tens of thousands of protesters
around parliament in the coming days the
government's very unlikely to agree to
what is being asked in fact it's
expanding oil and gas drilling in the
North Sea and says we will need fossil
fuels however unpopular for decades to
come
[Music]
it sets the scene for a spring and
summer of protest headline grabbing and
deeply divisive Hannah Thomas Peter Sky
News
[Music]
one woman told Sky News that she felt
like she'd been burgled after energy
firm workers forced their way into her
home to install a meter energy companies
have agreed to an outright ban on the
forced installation of prepayment meters
for people over the age of 85 and those
who are terminally ill the new measures
were called for after contractors
working for British gas were filmed
breaking into vulnerable households to
install the meters well there are
currently around four million prepayment
meters installed around the country with
customers paying around six percent more
than those without the new code of
practice bans the forced installation of
prepayment meters for the over 85s for
terminally ill and those who need
continuous power for health reasons
suppliers have now agreed to attempt to
contact a customer at least 10 times and
perform a site welfare visit before
installing the meters plus body cameras
or audio recorders must be worn during
installations and Welfare visits Sky's
Becky Johnson reports these are workers
from an energy company calling at the
home of a customer who owed money their
aim was to get in and force the
installation of a prepayment meter after
a few minutes they started to drill
through the door
the owner of the house in Birmingham was
at work at the time she agreed to speak
to us but wanted us to protect her
identity it felt as though I'd been
burgled I felt unsafe it just didn't
make any sense to me as to why they
needed to take that action I was
corresponding with them
due to problems with the wiring they
couldn't fit the meter but left a note
warning they'd be back this family in
London did have one fitted while they
were out
I literally had a panic attack the
neighbors actually came downstairs and
they actually came in
they heard me crying they heard me being
upset my mom didn't know what was going
on she's 90 years old so she just saw me
wandering around the flat hysterical
enforced installations of prepayment
meters were paused earlier this year
after this undercover footage caused
outrage
bit I love this bit but if they just
saying oh I'm a single mom and I've got
three kids and internet that's that's
not vulnerability it led to calls for
the practice to be banned altogether and
Charities say the new rules that only
restrict forced installations don't
protect enough people
well they've obviously picked 85 Plus
because it's the smallest group and they
want to maximize the number of people
that they can impose prepayment meters
on
um so yes it's great that those few
people are protected but that's a tiny
tip of the iceberg of the size of the
issue
the chief executive of off gems said it
must be as a last resort and customers
in vulnerable situations will be given
the extra care and consideration they
deserve over and above the rules already
in place by suppliers something that is
clearly not always been happening but by
stopping short of a ban more families
will find their homes are targeted if
they fall behind on their bills Becky
Johnson Sky News Birmingham
an 84 year old man charged with first
degree assault after shooting a black
teenager in the head and arm has
surrendered police in Missouri Rafael
was shot by Andrew Lester after
reportedly going to the wrong house to
pick up his younger twin brothers after
initially being detained Leicester was
released by police Spock in protests
throughout Kansas City over the weekend
our U.S correspondent James Matthews
reports
is the 16 year old who went to the wrong
door and almost paid for it with his
life
he'd been sent to pick up his two
younger brothers and mistakenly went to
this house home of 84 year old Andrew
Lester
according to police documents he says he
thought Ralph was breaking in when he
answered the doorbell immediately he
fought a handgun through a glass door
Ralph was shot in the head he told
police that when he fell he was hit a
second time in his arm he ran to
neighbors and received help not before
one told him to lie down with his hands
in the air according to a family lawyer
[Applause]
there had been protests after the man
who fired the shot was released after
less than two hours of police
questioning he's since been charged with
two crimes including assault
prosecutors speak of a racial component
to the shooting
Ralph hadn't gone to 115th Terrace where
his brothers were in Kansas City he went
to an address at 115th Street around the
corner it was a near fatal mistake
he went and rang the doorbell and he was
supposed to stay outside and his
brothers were supposed to run outside
get in the car and they and they come
home and that was what was supposed to
happen and while he was standing there
his brothers didn't run outside but he
got a couple of bullets in his body
instead of a couple of twins coming up
out and giving him a hug and the case
has turned heads in Hollywood actor
Halle Berry shared a thread on Twitter
saying she was sick and tired of this
feeling and that her heart completely
broke when she heard the news
byola Davis posted a series of pictures
on her Instagram feed and called for
charges to be brought against the man
who fired the gun
the incident May test Missouri's
so-called stand your ground law which
allows for deadly force in response to a
serious threat
a serious question would surround the
threat paused by a boy picking up his
brothers James Matthews Sky News in
Washington
whilst I'm breaking news tonight a
multi-story car park has partially
collapsed in New York's Manhattan
Financial District pictures appear to
show the third floor of the building
collapsing onto the second with reports
of several people trapped and at least
three people injured New York city mayor
Eric Adams is heading to the scene in
lower Manhattan these the latest
pictures for you
elsewhere more breaking news at least
four people have been severely injured
in a stabbing at a gym in the western
German city of deusberg police have
asked residents to avoid the area no
arrests were announced and the motive of
the attack is not immediately clear
they form a conservative cabinet
minister David Davis has warned hundreds
of thousands of people could be denied
their right to vote unless new
compulsory voter ID rules in England are
delayed our political correspondent Liz
Bates has been speaking to young people
in Hull who will have to show ID to vote
for the first time in next month's local
elections
200 miles from Westminster decisions
made there are Making Waves here the
port city of Hull
as new rules requiring voters to show ID
for the first time in England come into
Force for May's local elections
this Youth Center they fear the changes
will exclude the city's vulnerable
voters it's just another obstacles
people from underprivileged backgrounds
or for marginalized communities to work
for me personally I've never voted it's
just making it a barrier and we have
enough barriers already those without
valid ID like a passport or driver's
license can apply for free ID online but
the uptake has been low do you know how
to access free vote ID if you need it no
I had to ask when I know to help me do a
button paperwork and it's like because I
didn't know like big words or how to
like fill one in
unfortunately affected are the
unemployed the elderly those on benefits
and in rented housing making deprived
regions more vulnerable
is one of the areas where voters are
less likely to have a valid form of ID
but up and down the country there are
huge numbers of people without one up to
3.5 million many of them unaware that
they could be turned away next time they
try to vote the question in Westminster
though the government is determined to
press ahead I think in order to make
have absolute confidence in the ballot I
think saying you need some form of uh ID
in order to vote in person on the day is
a reasonable thing to request they say a
similar system has been used in Northern
Ireland since 2003 and the changes are
needed to stop electoral fraud this is
despite just one case across all UK
elections last year
and now a former Minister David Davis is
leading calls for a rethink I would at
very least just delay it if they do that
at least it avoids the worst outcome
which is that thousands tens of
thousands even hundreds of thousands of
people are prevented from voting back in
Hull they're preparing for what they
call their youth Parliament held every
two weeks is a forum where they can be
heard
but beyond the safety of the youth
center and in light of these new voting
rules they feel more ignored by those in
power than ever Liz Bates Sky News Hull
well that was kind is it 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this story on the front of the
Scotsman their headline the s p crisis
deepens they say after a second arrest
more on that and Other Stories of course
to come tonight we're joined by Sonia
Soda Chief leader writer at The Observer
and Mark Wallace chief executive of the
total politics group back in just a
moment
thank you
[Music]